zurück in afghanistan das land das ich
so viele jahre lang immer wieder besucht
habe so vielen mutigen frauen sind wir
begegnet noch im juni habe ich zur ifa
gefahren getroffen die als
bürgermeisterin einer provinzmetropole
den taliban über jahre die stirn geboten
und mordanschläge überlebt hat die
taliban sind in diesen wochen bereits
auf dem vormarsch erobern immer weitere
gebiete und bedrohen den traum von einem
weltoffenen modernen afghanistan in
kabul war die radfahrerin rucksack
piepser nicht bereit sich ihre freiheit
nehmen zu lassen und die journalistin
hat sie bei attac ball war voller
hoffnung dass die taliban nicht siegen
würden in den dramatischen tagen im
august nach dem fall kabuls erreichen
uns ihre verzweifelten nachrichten
hilferufe das land zu verlassen wir
halten kontakt versuchen zu unterstützen
mit erfolg tarifwahl rucksack hat sie
war und viele andere sind in sicherheit
aber was wird aus all jenen die
geblieben sind was bleibt von dem
afghanistan indem frauenträume hatten
fragen die mich bewegen auf meiner reise
die straße von der usbekischen grenze
nach masar i scharif führt durch wüsten
ähnliches land weil es noch keine
internationalen flüge gibt fahren wir
mit dem auto besser wäre ein alter
bekannter die nicht zuletzt im juni
getroffen hatte hat angeboten uns zu
begleiten bis vor kurzem noch war er
mitarbeiter eines deutschen
entwicklungshilfe projekts das liegt nun
auf eis kaum haben wir die stadt
erreicht schon der erste checkpoint der
taliban
was wollen sie möchte ich wissen ich
habe gesagt reporter aus deutschland da
haben sie gesagt okay das sind unsere
leute
die deutschen sind beliebt im norden
afghanistans als aufbauhelfer und auf
deutsche unterstützung hoffen auch die
taliban saberi möchte anders als viele
seiner kollegen bleiben er hat viel zu
verlieren seine eltern ein haus ein
leben das er sich aufgebaut hat er
fürchtet vor allem einen
wirtschaftlichen zusammenbruch des
landes
diese regierung hat keine ökonomische
unterstützung und auch keine einnahmen
wie wollen sie das land konnte
im moment sind banken in keiner guten
form ihnen geht das geld aus
in einigen tagen könnten sie von gott
erklären und die leute warten auf ihre
löhne
aber es gibt kein geld
plötzlich ruft uns eine gruppe von
taliban durch den zaun der moschee zu
sich wir durften hier nicht drehen es
ist hier nicht erlaubt sorgen sie
aber erreicht ein papier herr über die
genehmigung des sprechers der taliban
diese taliban papiere sind also unsere
sicherheit richtig
im augenblick ja wenn sie die papiere
sehen mit der unterschrift von mister
motörhead das ist gut
das papier mit der unterschrift des
taliban-sprechers reicht es den männern
gespanntes warten
er muss es lesen du siehst diese leute
die sind ungebildet sie sind mit 56
jahren zu den taliban gekommen und sind
auf nichts anderes als kämpfen trainiert
sie haben keine bildung das ist nicht
gut für die zukunft
hier in masar i scharif aber auch in
kabul arbeiten zu können und in der
öffentlichkeit drehen zu können brauchen
wir dieses papier von den taliban dass
wir immer vorzeigen wenn man uns fragt
was wir hier machen das gibt uns die
möglichkeit und ziel zu bewegen zu
drehen am nächsten tag probiere ich im
hotel die kleidung an die server für
mich auf dem basar gekauft hat eine
lange schwarze tunika und ein tuch
möglich nichts soll vom körper erkennbar
sein so schreiben es die taliban den
frauen vor die ernst dass bereits kleine
kinder nehmen werde ich wenig später
erleben
es ist feiertag zum freitagsgebet sind
viele menschen zur blauen moschee
gekommen den berühmten wahrzeichen und
herz der stadt eine gruppe straßenkinder
umringt mich ein kleines mädchen möchte
mir zeigen wie ich mein kopftuch besser
binden soll in rührender sorge darum ich
könnte mir den ärger der kämpfern zu
ziehen was wird mit ihnen passieren den
mädchen die noch ausgelassen toben meine
frage die mich nicht loslässt wir wollen
weiter nach kabul nach wochenlangem
stillstand haben die taliban den
flughafen von masar i scharif wieder
eröffnet es ist ein befremdliches gefühl
die terminals 1 vorzeige projekt
finanziert mit deutschen steuergeldern
direkt neben dem einstigen feldlager der
bundeswehr jetzt alles in händen der
taliban ihre flagge weht auch hier viele
der alten sicherheitsleute aber auch
stewardessen und piloten arbeiten
inzwischen wieder notgedrungen sondern
eindruck in einigen unbeobachteten
momenten nehmen uns immer wieder
menschen bei seite erzählen von ihrer
angst und ihrer hoffnung das land doch
noch verlassen zu können
landeanflug auf kabul unter uns liegt
der hamid karzai flughafen vor kurzem
noch schauplatz dramatischer szenen auf
der flucht vor den taliban für viele
menschen der einzige weg heraus aus dem
land
sarah navi ist geblieben ich treffe die
journalistin im fernsehstudio des
afghanischen frauen senders für den sie
bislang gearbeitet hat sie ist die
einzige die noch hier ist alle anderen
sind geflohen oder halten sich versteckt
sarah zeigt mir den blick vom balkon
über kabul hier will sie bleiben
wegrennen für sie eine schande
wir müssen hier bleiben und kämpfen
nicht nur für unsere eigenen rechte auch
für andere vielleicht werden sie uns
töten dann sterben wir das ist okay aber
vielleicht können wir auch etwas
erreichen für uns wie kann die chance
steht 50 zu 50 ist fünfter 5 d
am nächsten tag haben wir uns verabredet
um in einem park von kabul mit menschen
zu reden die auf ihrer flucht zurück
geblieben sind sofort werden wir umringt
vielleicht auch weil sarah immer wieder
verspricht etwas tun zukönnen zu helfen
eine frau zeigt papiere die ihre arbeit
für die entwicklungshelfer der gez
nachweisen sollen
bitte ich brauche sicherheit das hier
sind die menschen mit denen ich
gearbeitet habe
ich bin zum flugzeug gegangen und habe
meine unterlagen gezeigt aber die haben
mich aus dem flughafen rausgeworfen
nur raus aus afghanistan das wollen sie
alle hier und es sind vor allem die
jungen frauen die keine zukunft mehr
sehen in einem land unter herrschaft der
taliban
wir können hier nicht leben die taliban
wollen uns nicht leben lassen b du der
du und du exit the dome sie wollen uns
die frauen nicht akzeptieren
sie wollen dass frauen sie heiraten für
sie kinder bekommen
vor dem ein zelt mit ein paar decken für
die nacht zeigt mir details hier schlägt
sie mit ihrer mutter und vier
geschwistern seitdem sie vor einem monat
aus kunduz geflohen sind ab und zu
spenden menschen essen doch weitgehend
sind die menschen sich selbst überlassen
es ist erschütternd was mir hier vor
allem junge frauen erzählen die
situation ist katastrophal es gibt keine
sanitären anlagen sie wissen gar nicht
wie sie hier zur toilette gehen können
sie haben kein wasser manchmal auch
nichts zu essen und keine perspektive
hier rauszukommen sarah drängt zum auto
zurück zu gehen und den park zu
verlassen
wenn du irgendwo hingeht wo sich leute
versammeln musst du nach 15 minuten
gehen sonst wird es wirklich gefährlich
die taliban werden dich einkreisen und
ich befrage die können wir probleme
machen
wie sehr sich kabul in den wenigen
wochen verändert hat auf ihren pick ups
sind die taliban überall unterwegs hüter
über eine neue ordnung die die frauen am
härtesten trifft
ausradiert ihre gesichter von plakaten
und schaufenstern vertrieben alle die
die selbstbewusst und selbstbestimmt
auftreten das gebot ist sich unsichtbar
zu machen und es gilt für alle auch für
ausländische journalistin
wir werden den frauen erlauben
hinzugehen wo immer sie wollen solange
sie ihren angemessenen hijab tragen
wenn irgendeine ausländische frau in
unser land kommt dann bin ich sicher sie
ist aus gutem grund hier
aber auch sie muss draußen in vollem
hitler in einklang mit den islamischen
gesetzen gehen
als reporterin jetzt auf afghanistan zu
berichten empfinde ich als besonders
bedrückend hier zu sein und zu erleben
die frauen ihr recht auf
selbstbestimmung
genommen wird wir recht mensch zu sein
in einem restaurant im zentrum von kabul
treffen sich frauen die widerstand
leisten wollen sie haben mich eingeladen
zu ihrer runde wir dürfen nur mit dem
handy filmen um nicht aufzufallen
seitdem ihre letzten proteste von den
taliban brutal niedergeschlagen wurden
debattieren sie wie es weitergehen soll
wir haben viel erfahrung mit
pressekonferenzen vor der
taliban-herrschaft
wir wissen einfach nicht was jetzt
passieren wird wir sollten sehr
vorsichtig sein und die anderen frauen
schützen
wir sollten uns nicht in zu großen
gruppen versammeln
ich stimme zu unserer konferenz sollte
im keller eines gebäudes stattfinden das
noch nicht fertig ist und wir sollten
nur journalisten einladen ja die medien
spielen so eine wichtige rolle unsere
einzige hoffnung ist dass die welt druck
auf die taliban ausgeübt
weil es zu riskant ist im restaurant ein
interview zu führen der besitzer könnte
uns an die taliban verraten beschließen
wir maria wie nach hause zu begleiten in
der wohnung in der sie mit ihrer mutter
alleine lebt zeigt mir mariam handy
aufnahmen von den letzten protesten bei
denen sie dabei war tränengas und
schüsse in die luft hätten die taliban
abgefeuert gegen unbewaffnete frauen ist
es das wert sein leben zu riskieren
möchte ich wissen
alle mädchen aber auch alle jungen
afghanistans hatten früher pläne
hoffnungen seine zukunft du kannst dir
das sicher vorstellen wenn ein mensch
all seine hoffnungen und pläne verliert
dann spielt die sorge um dein leben
keine rolle
roth sich die geschichte zu wiederholen
oder sind die kämpfer die sich in den
straßen von kabul
furchteinflößend aufbauen anders als das
terrorregime der 90er jahre am rande der
straße erleben wir menschen die sich
verzweifelt vor den banken drängen angst
haben ihr geld zu verlieren und einen
taliban der mit der peitsche droht wenn
zu sehr gedrängelt wird auf dem weg
durch die stadt gerät der verkehr immer
wieder ins stocken dutzende von
straßenkindern umringen unser auto
manche schubsen sich gegenseitig weg
flehen uns um geld und essen an das ist
alltag in afghanistan
es ist ein trauriger abschied wenig
später von unseren afghanischen kollegen
wir werden zurückkommen weiter berichten
[Musik]